[Music]
today's question comes from jason in
illinois jason writes
my question is about income from a side
hustle
i recently began sports betting and have
built up a bankroll of about four
thousand dollars so his side hustle is
gambling
my wife and i have about fifty five
thousand dollars in total debt excluding
the house we earn about 61 grand a year
i'm a saver said the gambler my wife is
a spender we don't have a budget and
need an additional 500 bucks to cover
our bills for the month
i have agreed to withdraw this my
favorite sentence i've ever read on the
show
i have agreed to withdraw 250 bucks a
month from my sports betting account to
help cover our shortage but my wife
would prefer i liquidate the account
dave what should i do
oh man this is a real person
oh man there's a human out there that
really asked that
if we don't say something stupid we're
going to be employed forever
forever
oh man all right so i'll jason you're
not jason you're not from the south or
around the south we would say bless your
heart bless your heart so number one
uh gambling is not a side hustle
because you're not that good you
prideful arrogant little jerk it's an
addiction
it's an addiction number two you're not
a saver
you're a gambler
i
i
i
sometimes
like this guy sounds like he he thinks
he's not playing
he he thinks he's so good at it that's a
guaranteed income yes that's what i
meant by you arrogant prideful little
jerk that's what i was saying
yeah he there's an arrogance that goes
with this type of addiction
that he thinks he's the exception of the
rule and he thinks that
mgm grand
was built
by santa claus instead of by bettors who
lost their butts exactly caesar
right in his palace yes
so liquidate this immediately all four
thousand
put all four thousand dollars close all
of your sports betting
accounts take your wife out for a cheap
meal and say you are sorry and that you
have lied to her and you've been
dishonest and you're gonna go get help
and
then go get a second job
that you work for and that pays you
every time and you earn money and stuff
and never say you have a 250 a month
side
betting account no no no no no he has
four thousand dollars that's his money
that he earned and he was going to bless
his little wife by allowing her to use
250 of his 4 000
because he's that kind of business
account he's a sweet guy that way
no more separate accounts now you hear
all the sarcasm folks i just wanna make
sure you heard sarcasm in there because
that's uh it's important that you heard
that
you arrogant little self-centered
unbelievable
you need help son just don't say it
because you're gonna get us canceled no
i'm not gonna get canceled i own the
show how can i cancel me that'd be nice
of you no i was just kidding listen man
you're not you're not
i don't know how to say this you're not
well i i a a buddy of mine who's a
pastor here in town walked me through
the increase in sports betting oh yeah
in tennessee yeah
astounding period no the number one
fastest growing addiction in america
online porn number two online gambling
and most of it is sports but i didn't
see the money we have we have a cool
dude named caesar doing commercials give
me a break here
unbelievable the amount of money
funny i have talked to 25 people in the
past
handful of months that are lost their
families their businesses their jobs
their their wife is done and it's all
because he thought he was cute betting
football
and it starts there it's just i'm sorry
you're not cute dude and you're not cute
looking at porn either i'm not it's not
funny
it's not funny you're a wuss and you
need help you need help and you've got
you are messed up
uh this is uh you know and you can just
read your own email how messed up you
are you have four thousand dollars and
your wife who is the only person on the
planet who actually thinks you're cool
wants some money
and you are going to give her 250 of
your 4 000. i want to choke you
your job is to serve your family not
your sports betting addiction
so
there is no got there is no data that
says that people whose sports bet end up
wealthy as a matter of fact there's a
ton of data that indicates that the
person that you're betting with ends up
wealthy and you end up with nothing
there is no data that says that when you
um
act like that you own everything and you
are throwing
coins what what's the thing for mary
poppins tuppence to the poor
you're throwing tuppence to the poor
like your poor little wife we're going
to give her a tuppet or whatever that
was i can't remember that she's not a
poor little wife though dave she's the
spender yeah she's the spender he's the
saver see dude you are so there's so
many
here's the thing about this email jason
some people
quite a few in fact can have a one or
two drinks they can go to dinner have a
drink have gloss wine have a cocktail
um
some though can't
ever again
some people can get together with their
buddies and put 25 bucks in on something
or you know go to vegas once a year what
you my friend probably you're not that
person and so i'm suggesting you might
have to close this account and never
open it again uh
not maybe you do
ever because the language you're using
indicates you got all kinds of issues
that are having anything to do with
sports betting right and the sports
betting is going to get exasperated i
see it all in the language yes you you
have to call somebody and say i'm not
okay you're not okay you're a sick puppy
gosh i hope we weren't unclear
[Laughter]
so it sounds like we're making fun of
you because we are okay
and i'm not so much i we are no you are
you you're like this is the worst email
i've ever had you know people like this
are on the planet we're always going to
be implementing that's true you are
making fun of him but i mean here's the
thing dude it's so you're so it's so
messed up that it's impossible to not
make fun of it and give
you a loving kind gentle answer with a
straight face without being sarcastic
because it's so everything in this is so
freaking absurd that's that's it's the
absurdity so put the addiction aside
this is the way you treat your wife is
absurd the way you
the way you think that this is a side
hustle is absurd
though way you think this is saving
you're a saver is absurd
everything in here is absurd and so the
absurdity has to be addressed and we're
doing that with sarcasm and humor go get
a job we just don't know what else to do
go get help go get a job